I love my friends we meet again it's
been a while where should we begin it
feels like forever but it's only been a
week since we lasted the lobby drowning
in the water it's a great reference it's
Austin's creative sausage crazy look
he's playing a sauce is great you
playing his house is great oh yeah why
aren't you a baby um I grew up kind of
on the outside I did in the words of a
new band when you have to crawl before
you can murder so which is nice that's
pretty good what do you do in Jeremy
Jane are you also zombies Sam bees just
some Sammy show the people show the
people at home you can be a zombie
what's your favorite creed song ah Karen
your turn we're her I don't know oh that
one thanks I'm some what's your favorite
creed song Oh none of them hey are you
working on I'm working on this awesome
game called register for comic-con it
involves a lengthy PDF process in which
I have to prove that I'm part of the
press really yeah way wearing the cup is
I'm gonna email this to them yeah you're
not let have on her husband's oh [ __ ]
speaking of Assassin's Creed unitard how
you doing my buddy hello Brigid see it's
good to have you in America let's get
rid of clothes and Assassin's Creed on
talk too much better because we're gonna
talk about in the show you enjoyed it uh
bits of it yeah it's a bit look at this
point 7i 0 10 bits of it ok I talk to
you about why you took those three
points off because that's how reviews or
on the show yeah well that's begun the
show today that's its Creed we got halo
which multiplayer this morning and on
master chief collection has been super
spotties we're gonna try and play it if
it doesn't work we will play the single
player Chris waters been playing that
he's not playing it now he's playing
Assassin's Creed of course Mary's gonna
play massive chalice as well hey what's
up hey could you do me a favor yeah
you're really good at doing French
accents but like a French Assassin's
Creed accents could you give me your
best French Assassin's Creed accent
please oi I'm gonna stab you your
[ __ ] throat hey go why is it those
all ancient people of British like
regardless even if it's France which
couldn't be nice British I don't know
Alexa wave at the camera
it was some new peeps too old and new
BAM Chris waters hello a baby anymore i
growed stub you murdered anyone yet no
uh yeah well kind of a little bit sort
of but it wasn't me it was another guy
am I supposed to tackle this guy oh god
I want you to be in prime murdering
condition by the time we start the show
we're gonna slide show with Mary play
master Chavez which you played a bunch
of this week and Brad mirror who should
be sitting on the couch right now hey
there Brad right there are you there hey
there Brad hey there Bright Eric teh egg
teh overwatch will have that in the show
next year the hype is real life is real
all right 2 p.m. pacific on lobby we'll
see you guys there gamespot com Joel